and you have to be great in auditions I
hate auditioning I don't like like I'm
not insane I don't like I don't like
auditioning I like I like acting right
right right you know if you're doing
scenes with a really great coach there's
nothing more free than that other than
doing like black box theater right where
it's just like come if you feel like it
don't if you don't feel like it
auditioning sucks yes and I've hated
auditioning since I was started
auditioning it just sucks it's the are
you good at it though I don't know I
mean what kind of feedback you know I've
had this these questions and these
conversations with other actors and
they're like you know all casting
directors will always give you feedback
feedback to your agency he was great
he's just he's just not they're going in
a different direction or he's great we
haven't made a decision he's always
great he's always great and I'm like I
got to get to the bottom of this yeah I
can't always be great not everybody's
great and I talked to a casting director
and I go why do you casting directors
always say great
he was great
because honestly it's because if that
person becomes a star or that person
exactly demand we want to bring them in
so they sort of lie and which it's
easier to say he did a good job but
we're not you know yeah instead of
saying your client is one of the worst
actors I've ever seen what a piece of
[ __ ] that was yeah he didn't take any
time I mean occasionally you'll get some
but like but that requires a lot of
hubris like you think about I'm reading
one of um I love reading uh uh to
Anthony shares books the you know the
the South African uh Shakespearean actor
who died not too long ago and
he was saying
um passages just reading the other day
about how he applied to every major
British acting school when he first got
to England and he was rejected like you
just said by like Radha said not only
were you terrible but you should
absolutely not act you know really 15
years later he was knighted and doing
every major Shakespeare part at the as
the you know the top actor at the RSC so
I think to be fair to casting directors
they don't know
right I think it's safer for them to say
someone was great because they don't
know you might have had a shitty day you
may be great you know I think that what
did help me being a young actor as far
as that goes with auditioning
um was I started so young and I got a
lot of affirmation from people like Yul
Brynner and folks like that who are like
like look you know you've got something
keep working on it don't listen to
anyone don't read reviews
and I that was some really good advice
just do the work that you think is good
like within yourself that's the best you
can do and I know that that's like to an
actor like you know you hear that you're
like yeah right if you have a bad day
you're like that's not gonna penetrate
your head right you're just gonna think
oh I'm just I just suck
um but it does resonate in my head and
that's one of the reasons I like to
train is like if I do I might have a
shitty audition and I've just done an
amazing run with my Shakespeare
monologue with my coach and I know I
don't suck you know what I mean yeah I
just I wasn't either right for it or I
didn't hit it right or somebody was rude
in the in the casting room and it set me
off or whatever
um you know you have to have narrative
still to do any of this stuff yeah and
you have to smile and but I direct a lot
and some on the other side of that
equation a lot and it you know I I and
it helps me in my doc work a lot because
I really care about making the people
I'm working with feel comfortable and
that they can trust me and that that's
genuine and that I have their back yeah
because as an actor you often don't have
anyone who has your back yeah